Film Courage: We took a break for a moment and
off-camera you said something about
character and dialogue and how you help
your students and how in some ways a lot
of it...they're the same thing? Corey Mandell, Screenwriter/Instructor: In some
ways yeah. And I talked about this
sort of more globally in the creative
integration video that people can go
back that I did for you guys a couple
years ago I'll I'll I'll give a little
more specific so there's a little more
specifics on the intuitive training and
and there'll be a practical test that
people can take at the end to see where
they're at sort of so when I work with
someone especially someone who needs to
improve on their characters and dialogue
and I'm going to short-stroke this a
little bit because you can go back to
the creative integration video for a
full explanation of the conceptual in
the intuitive but often that the
conceptual brain is very focused on what
other people think fear of rejection
want it to be good and it's controlling
and that can be helpful and and there's
certainly when we're doing story
designing we wanted design stories don't
even really engaging other people we
want to be aware of how people are
seeing our scripts so the conceptual
brain is a really important part in this
but the intuitive brain is where our
authenticity comes from our emotional
authenticity and the intuitive brain
doesn't have a past present or a future
just hasn't now and so the first part of
what I'm working with someone to get
them better at characters and or
dialogue the first thing is to train
them through practic ated practice to
build to turn off the conceptual brain
and just work from a pure intuitive
space and the metaphor I would give them
is imagine sounds crazy but you ride
your horse to work so that's how you get
to work and you have to get to work in
half an hour and your horse likes to
wander and wants to go grazing and look
at waterfalls but you have to control
the horse because you got to get to work
and you make sure that your horse gets
you to work in half an hour and this
metaphor you the writer or the
conceptual brain and the horse is the
intuitive part of it
and so the first thing is to release and
surrender control to the horse and let
the horse go wherever the horse wants to
go and don't control it and don't even
judge it it's almost like you just get
off the horse and this you know for this
day the horse can do whatever it wants
and so training people and this this is
the hardest part of the training and it
can take weeks it can take a month or
two but it's literally learning how to
just get a prompt and just immediately
start writing without any ideas of story
without any control without any editing
it's just letting that intuitive
instinct take over and just go wherever
it goes and it's like it's like a dream
in that it doesn't have to be logical it
doesn't have to be interesting it's just
has to be authentic and real and really
stressed non-performance writing
no one's gonna read this so to warm up
by people do journaling they'll journal
for fifteen or twenty minutes because
when we're journaling especially if no
one reads our journals what do we
navigate toward we're not trying to be a
good writer or interesting writer we're
just trying to navigate towards the
truth you know trying to find our truth
or exploring a topic or just trying to
maybe just writing about how we feel and
that's non-performance writing you know
as opposed to when we fire up final
draft or whatever software we use it's
like I'm gonna write something and
people are gonna read it and they're
gonna judge it and they're by by default
they're gonna judge me or certainly it
feels that way
so this first level of training is
learning how to turn off the conceptual
brain and literally it's like
trance-like writing you you eventually
get to the place where you could do this
for 20 minutes 30 minutes 45 minutes and
when you're done you don't even remember
what you wrote it's just completely
authentic intuitive lead writing so
that's the first step I mean that's not
getting you to great characters in
dialogue but that's the first step on
the journey would to use another
metaphor I would say it's like if I was
teaching someone yoga but they couldn't
they were so non limber that
get down to the floor this first phase
is just getting down to the floor it's
not actual yoga but it's getting some
ones they can get down to the floor so
that's the first phase and it's the
hardest phase for most writers so when
they can get to a point where they can
write no judging no editing completely
intuitive surrender control of the horse
and just trance-like writing then we go
to the second phase and the second phase
is I'm going to teach them how to write
from a really really provocative
emotional feeling an autobiographical
event like the best most one you know
when their child was born or when their
father died I mean we're talking like
primal moments and I'm gonna train them
how to write in a way where they let the
feeling that they're feeling this
emotion leave the writing and they're
gonna do it to the point and keep
practicing until myself or someone else
when they read these pages they can feel
what the writer felt so they can they
can it's a now and energy transference
and emotional transference to be able to
really engage us with characters and
dialogue you're gonna have to be able to
do this now there are people listening
to this who don't need any training to
do this they are very deep intuitive's
they they absolutely can do this right
now without any training but there are
people that need structured training to
get to this point where they can let go
of their control ego-mind work from a
pure intuitive space and write in a way
where people can feel what they feel
then we go to phase 3 and in phase 3
there's techniques to start to discover
actual characters and you interview
these characters you spend time with
these characters and there's a bunch of
play exercises till the character will
take over and will happen is you can
start writing and you put the character
in some situation and they just do what
they would do and they just say what
they would say and they are driving it
you're not you have no agenda now maybe
what the character is doing or saying
isn't particularly interesting might not
make for
story but the character is doing what
they do insane what they would say then
the next phase is learning how to write
where what the character is feeling the
reader can feel so now we can
emotionally bond and connect with the
character we can feel what they're
feeling that's really powerful and again
some writers naturally do this and some
writers naturally don't do anything
close this but through this training
they can get there then the next phase
is we will find another character that
they spend time do this training with so
they'll eventually have two characters
that they always know what that
character would do they always know what
that character would say and they have
they have surrender control to the
characters we'll put the characters in a
certain situation a certain basic
conflict and they very slowly will go
back and forth writing it from inside
each character so this character would
do that what with this character do whoa
a dis character is a response and now
the characters are creating what happens
now again maybe what's happening is
really compelling and riveting maybe
it's not maybe it's really boring it
doesn't matter it's the characters doing
what the characters would do in
interaction with each other and so
ultimately and here's something that
someone can do right now if they want to
test their ability this is where I would
say someone comes out the other end
earning their intuitive merit badge so
to speak which is so ultimately where we
want to get to is organic story
structure which is a it's a term that's
used a lot but not often really
understood so the way I would define it
is organic means everything the
characters do it feels like they would
really do it everything the character
says feels like they would really say it
there's never a moment where you see the
hand of the writer there's never a
moment where fills in organics there's
never a moment where a character is
doing a preordained plot point or a
character's doing something or saying
something because the writer wanted them
to do they're saying this to drive the
story forward a certain way that's
organic
story structure means everything that's
happening is the most compelling choice
from a story point of view and the story
keeps getting more and more interesting
it's really hard for writers to do both
to do organic story structure because in
the best scripts the the scripts that
can change or writers life you read the
script and you never see a hand never
see the hand the writer it never feels
inorganic it just feels like these
characters these are real people they'll
have a unique voice they're all saying
what they would say they're all doing
what they would do and it's never boring
it is just captivating ly interesting it
gets more and more interesting that's
the Holy Grail when a writer can do that
they are the needle in the haystack that
the industry is looking for everyone
will want to meet that writer and work
with that writer so the first step I
would tell people and this is what we're
talking about this question is the
organic so let's take story structure
off the table excuse me so with organic
what I would tell someone is this is how
we know you've successfully come you
successfully come through the end of
this training or sometimes writers will
come to me and I'm like you seem like
you really strong intuitive skill sets
maybe you don't need to do this training
let's test where you're at so this is
what I would have them do I would have
them take two or three characters that
they know they love these characters
these characters have unique voices they
know exactly what these characters would
do or say and we're gonna put them into
a conflict a situation and they're gonna
write it doesn't it's not going to be a
full scripts not going to be a whole
pilot or a future we don't need to do
that let's say 25 pages and what I tasks
the writer with doing is just let the
characters do whatever they would do and
say whatever they would say don't worry
if it's interesting don't worry about
you know context and it being funny or
dramatic it could be boring it just has
to be completely organic and when you're
done we're gonna take these 25 pages and
we're gonna give it to five or six
people that you trust and you're gonna
give each of them a red marker and
you're going to explain what you did
you're gonna say I know this sounds
crazy but I don't care if what you're
reading is interesting I don't care if
it's boring I don't care if it's
illogical all I care about is it 100%
organic do all the characters speak with
the unique voice do the characters all
the time feel like they're doing what
they would really do saying what they
would really say if there's ever a
moment where you're like I'm not sure I
believe the character would have said
that I don't know if the character was
motivated to say that or felt little
force that they did that or felt like
you were controlling or any of that
market circle with red put a red mark on
it it's okay again it's completely
boring we're going for organic and if
you get the seven drops back without any
red lines you have your intuitive merit
badge which means you are capable of
organic now you're not going to take
those 25 pages and go out to the
marketplace with it but you can do
organic then and this is this would be a
longer conversation for another day then
you have to train yourself on story
structure and then it's a matter of
putting the two together to have organic
story structure but in terms of
character and dialogue going through
those stages and coming out where you
can be fully organic is a huge move
forward because now when someone reads
your script they're gonna feel like
these are real people and the dialogue
is gonna feel real and these characters
are going to have emotional in our lives
and we're going to believe each of the
characters that's the first part then
when you can do that integrated with
story design with story structure then
you get to those magical scripts where
everything is organic and authentic and
it the story is absolutely grabs our
attention holds our attention and
delivers us somewhere that exceeds our
expectations and I have seen the
challenge that a lot of people make as
they try to learn to do all of that at
once and it's really difficult it's like
you know trying to Bowl when you have
that 10 4 split the two pins are as far
apart and if you try to with one ball
knocked both pins down usually do so
what I
trained people to do is just focus on
organic just be able to nail that then
sort of the peek in how I trained
writers and the workshops will also
train people to just do story structure
with like puppets it can be inorganic
where you know how to design the most
compelling story even if it's completely
inorganic and feels like you're
controlling the characters that's ok
we're not going to take that and show it
to anyone in the industry this is all
training but then when you can do story
structure and then you can do organic or
you can do organic and then you can do
story structure then I can teach you how
to put the two together where they
integrate so I always teach these
separately
you